Paul Bettany is a good friend that
you've done drugs with right
that's a strange question
um Paul Bettany is a good friend
yes you've done drugs with him yes I
have cocaine right uh cocaine is alcohol
yes pills including Xanax and Adderall
right
um
that I'm not too sure of okay Mr Depp
you you remember giving testimony in the
trial in the UK correct
yes and you gave that testimony under
oath right
yes
um
you were you were
you gave quite a bit of testimony in
that trial right
uh I wouldn't be able to
judge that myself it felt like a lot
okay well let's take a look at some of
it and you see that uh on on the bottom
of that page
there's a discussion of of Paul Bettany
and and the things
drugs that you did together and there
was a question the question is any sort
of pills and your answer is yes there
could have been Xanax or if he needed if
he asked for Xanax or Adderall whatever
I would of course give it to him
question so you would Supply Paul
Bettany with whatever medication or
controlled drugs he asked for is that
right
answer if he was feeling anxious or if
he was feeling unpleasant I would give
him what he asked for question would you
give him a Xanax answer yes
did I read that right you certainly did
yes sir
and you shared
um the two of you shared an enjoyment of
controlled drugs or alcohol at that time
right
um
the two of us were making a film uh
together
um with respect to that that wasn't my
question my question was the two of you
shared an enjoyment of controlled drugs
and alcohol at that time yes or no
at times and
misheard was quite adamant that you
didn't drink anymore and that you should
stop using recreational drugs right
oh yes and she didn't like it when you
were high on drugs or drunk on alcohol
right
she didn't like it when it was her
perception that I was high on drugs her
perception is quite different than the
truth
and that's that's what we're after is
the truth Mr Depp this this is a text
message exchange that you had with Paul
Bettany
on June 11 2013. correct yes
correct you text Mr Bettany let's burn
Amber 3x exclamation points right you
see that produce you though
and at this time June 11 2013 Amber is
your girlfriend or perhaps even your
fiance at this point correct
girlfriend yeah for sure after that you
made another comment and and I'd like to
apologize to the court and to the jury
for some of the language that I'm gonna
have to use today but unfortunately
um
you're going to see a lot of documents
with language like this
after you've said let's drown her before
we burn her Mr Depp you said I will for
burnt corpse afterwards to make sure she
is dead
that's what you said that you would do
after you burned her and after you
drowned her did I read that right
you certainly did yes and you wrote that
about the woman who would later become
your wife
yes I did on January 17 2013 Mr Depp
you texted
the following
for the idiot cow
three exclamation points next text
will do
I'll smack the ugly around before I let
her in don't worry
apologies again to the court and the
jury for this language
and then you close by saying did that
worthless hooker arrive did I read that
right
yeah you did so
um one of your good friends that you've
taken drugs with before is Marilyn
Manson right
[Music]
um
yes we've taken we've drank
together we've
we've we've had cocaine together maybe a
couple of times
um pills right
with Marilyn Manson
um
I once gave Marilyn Manson a pill uh so
that he would
stop talking so much
sorry all right
um
I get it and on line 22 you were asked a
question the night before you were due
to meet up did you have a heated
discussion on the telephone with
misheard about what was happening with
James Franco the scene she was doing
with James James Franco answer I do not
recall but it is highly likely did I
read that right
in fact I'm not sure where you are okay
um day two page 293 it's on page 32 of
the document line 22 I think is the
issue
page 32 line 22. thank you your honor
line 22. line 22 on page 32. yes too
many too many numbers
are you there yes yes okay so question
the night before you were due to meet up
did you have a heated discussion on the
telephone with misheard about what was
happening with James Franco the scene
she was doing with James Franco answer I
do not recall but it is highly likely
did I read that right you did and you
suspected that Amber was having an
affair with James Franco correct
that was the reason for your argument
um
yeah yes let's do this so is it your
testimony that right after you cut your
finger off that you or right after I I
won't give you anything to argue with me
yet right after you sustained an injury
to your finger
that's right that you
right after you sustain an entry to your
finger is it your testimony that you did
not ask for cocaine and ecstasy
right after you told the doctor about
your finger injury is that your
testimony
um
regardless of what date you believe
works within the World Time Zone
um I don't believe that
someone who has gone through
opiate dependency who has lost the
ability
to to produce dopamine and serotonin in
their own body because
um that's what the opiate does your body
no longer needs to make the dopamine or
the serotonin the dopamine and serotonin
as you know I imagine are
um things that keep us
um
in in in in in it gives us our moods I
appreciate that but my question wasn't
that my question was I'm just trying to
call the doctor about your finger injury
you were asking for Coke it's entirely
possible that you were asking for
cocaine and ecstasy objection yes or no
speculation
I I'll allow that question answer it uh
clearly need why these more Whitey stuff
um is is is uh yes it's a reference to
cocaine but that doesn't uh there's
nothing here that says that I ingested
the drug not saying there is but you
were asking for more cocaine and you
were asking for more ecstasy correct
I wasn't asking for more ecstasy I was
asking for ecstasy because that was what
I was requested from was requested by
Missouri this is this is where you tell
Amber in a recording that you mentioned
the day I chopped my finger off so let's
listen to that right you're talking
about I'm talking about Australia today
now we're talking about Australia okay
yeah
you hear that and you said the day I
chopped my finger off
let's let's play it again thank you
fight you're talking about I don't know
I'm talking about Australia now we're
talking about Australia okay
are you sure that's
yeah let's do it one more time
that I got my finger chopped off no no
you saved the day that I chopped my
finger off so let's play it one more
time because I think I left out the word
that it says the day that I chopped my
finger off
okay
I'm not so sure in fact earlier you had
quoted Jerry judge from uh the airplane
tape is calling me
um wait till he falls asleep and I'm
positive that those words never left his
mouth because he was
he would have if I would have been
making those noises in the bathroom he
would have ripped the hinges off
maybe they left his mouth when you were
passed out sir respectfully
let's listen to this one more time
staying as argumentative and I'll move
to strike can you please bring up
defendants exhibit 638
[Music]
I'm sorry what what is are we going to
enter this into evidence sir yes your
honor move for the admission of this
video into evidence
we have no objection your honor all
right 638 in evidence thank you now you
can publishing
[Music]
what happened
what happened
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
no nothing happened to you this morning
yeah you're right I just woke up and you
were so sweet
we're not even fighting this morning all
I did was say sorry did something happen
you
this morning I don't think so
um
no that's the thing you want to see
crazy
[Music]
oh really
[Music]
really
[Music]
I didn't you were smashing
[Music]
do we have a date for this um
we have a table and metadata or anything
on that why don't we let's since you
have some questions about it let's why
don't we watch it again
oh I've seen it again
okay we you know what we we can we don't
have to do that that's good we don't
have to do that
this is at your house in West Hollywood
on Suites or Avenue correct that's
correct and that's you in the video Mr
Depp right
that's correct and you would agree that
you were violent In that clip correct
um
clearly I was having a bad time
I don't uh I don't know what it was with
regard to completely at this point since
I don't know the day but um
um being legally recorded by
your
um
chosen others
uh
well it's quite fitting with the rest of
the photographs
tape recordings she made so
um I thought what was most interesting
is that she tried to hide it from me and
then that she laughed and smiled at the
end
I thought that was most interesting part
myself but so yes I did assault
um a couple of cabins but I did not
touch Miss heard and as you can see I
think you know and you may have been you
may have been may have been drunk in
that video correct
possibility of that yes sir you poured
yourself a a mega pint of red wine
correct
a mega pint
yeah
I poured myself a large glass of wine
right I thought it necessary and what I
would propose to play is 3210 to 3805 so
we'll make it 586 a section 32 10
through 38.05 all right yes I think
thank you and with your permission I'd
ask uh for us to play this okay Jerry go
ahead thank you
actually before we start Mr Depp during
this meeting that you had with her at
one point you tried to cut yourself with
a knife correct
I don't recall that no okay let's play
this I mean I might have
made a move
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is really pretty thanks
do I want to cut you yeah
on the chest
[Music]
just don't cut your skin please do not
cook your skin please don't okay
why would I do that you see don't please
do not do that please do not do that
don't please stop
I need to do what I want
I know and how it hurts
[Music]
no thank you no thank you this on the
pillows
[Music]
I know
never cut you
I would never do that to you
[Music]
get on my arms
no
because
it's gonna go to court
it's really tall
don't don't don't don't don't
please don't do that Put The Knife Down
Put The Knife Down
don't
don't do that
do not do that Tony
please you're gonna look at you you're
gonna hurt yourself please I want to
look at you
[Music]
stop please don't wait for the pain to
go away it's not that it doesn't make
you go away trust me and do you know it
doesn't make you go away really
did it make you go away yeah yeah it did
please don't please don't do that okay
[Music]
just look here
there is looking
here for no other reason to be here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to use to cut me with
it would be too painful and dull and
dirty to use it
right it's pretty
no no please do not do not do don't
don't you're gonna hurt yourself
don't
please don't cut yourself please please
don't
please stop please stop please
don't don't hurt yourself please
[Music]
help myself
your honor I think that might if it's
okay with your honor I probably gonna
move on to something else later okay I
assume you still have quite a bit Cross
or
a bit I'm not not exactly sure all right
but more than we could do yes okay all
right that's fine all right ladies and
gentlemen it looks like we've come to
the end of our week